the media drumbeat continued today and
into the night about all the salacious
tidbits in the new White House tell-all
by Michael Wolfe among the most off
repeated tropes in the book are that
President Trump is not smart he doesn't
read he's not curious you know he's just
kind of a village idiot type according
to Wolf's book and many of this has been
pushed back on by the way former deputy
chief of staff Katie Walsh thought the
White House was in confidently run
Treasury secretary Steve munchin and
former chief of staff Reince Priebus
believed Trump to be an idiot Gary Cohen
the president's top economic adviser
regards Trump as quote dumb and the
president's top national security
adviser HR McMaster considers him
according to this book to be quote a
dope oh of course all of this thrilled
the lefty cabled nitwits
and bitter never Trump firs some of the
more salacious entries the fact that
Donald Trump doesn't read well you know
we told you that a year and a half ago
the assessments all consistent of the
closest people of the president working
with him as being essentially a child
he's a child
he's got no attention span he reads
nothing it's even worse than it seems
this is an idiot surrounded by clowns
the behavior the disposition of the
president they say he's acting like a
child the horrible choice you have to
make is do I stay here and work with
this child who behaves like an arrogant
fool behaves like a baby pot kettle
black Joe well of course they're all joy
enjoying this moment we're team Trump
seems to be piling on the president
because they all think it validates
their own views that Donald Trump is
just a troglodyte who lucked out by
winning the presidency and by the way he
eats a lot of bad food okay I'm gonna
hand it to them I think they're right
about this Trump isn't into artisanal
cheeses
he doesn't munch on kale and down
coconut water but most of the rest of
this stuff it's just goofy first
do these perpetual grocers realize that
when you call him an imbecile you are in
effect saying the same of his supporters
I mean I'm not a political soothsayer
but I don't think that's a great
political strategy for expanding your
own movement and by the way I still
remember what the intellectuals of the
late 1970s and the 80s frequently said
about my old boss Ronald Reagan remember
he was unintelligent he slept in the
afternoons he went to a second-rate
College just an actor shallow well look
Trump isn't Reagan no one ever will be
Reagan was a man for his own time he was
a former two-term Governor of California
who wrote and thought a lot about
conservatism but like Reagan Trump is
extremely sharp and he has the pulse of
the people and I know because I've seen
it he has an uncanny ability to connect
with their hopes and their desires and
like Reagan he reminds Americans that
what makes us special is our people it's
our freedom it's not our government and
as for the so-called smart educated
people who are now criticizing Trump I
have a few questions
was it smart to enact policies that
ended up enriching the repressive regime
in China at the expense of American
workers American companies and American
security and was it smart to leave our
borders open like Swiss cheese allowing
illegals to stream into the United
States
taking American jobs saddling taxpayers
with the cost of educating them housing
them providing them with health care was
it smart to get into some wars that
ended up draining our country of
trillions of dollars took the lives of
so many of our finest men and women was
it smart to explode our foreign
population not through a smart
merit-based immigration system but
through the ludicrous policy of chain
migration was it smart to borrow
trillions from other countries only to
send hundreds of billions to countries
who hate us is it smart to create a
government mandated health care system
that drove so many doctors out of their
practices jacked up premiums and
out-of-pocket costs and led to canceled
policies I don't think so
truck friend and political operative
Roger stone put it this way on my radio
show today Donald Trump is his own chief
strategist
he's also his own speechwriter his own
phrase maker his own press secretary in
many senses and he's obviously very good
at it yes Donald Trump is an eccentric
yes he does things his way yes he is not
like every other president that you can
think of who was packaged who was
fabricated who was being handed you know
polling and and focus groups and and in
discussions of how to say things that
would make you popular against enormous
odds by taking on the two-party duopoly
and these the elites of both parties
that who have let's face it run the
country into the ground he's a genius
so maybe Donald Trump doesn't pour over
Robert Caro's latest doorstop size
biography or have dog-eared copies at
Plato's Republic on his bedside table
big deal he had great schooling but he
never pretended to be an academic not
many people are but what did he do he
exposed and named the pretenders those
elites in politics media and business
who helped drive America into a ditch
and by the way no matter how badly their
policies and ideas failed the people
those fraudsters are almost never held
accountable so tired of seeing America
lose Trump revealed their agendas he
named them and he made us see the them
to be the frauds that they are and by
the way they've been vengeful ever since
furious well what's the point of being
smart if you never learn trump was smart
enough to see that someone needed to
step up to be the voice of the forgotten
man and woman and he beat all those
supposedly savvy and experienced
campaigners with their focus group
tested talking points and slick ad
campaigns it's smart to put Americans in
their interest first and Donald Trump is
out there still listening to the people
who count you I was
New York and a big event recently and I
take a lot of pictures with police and
with firemen and with the military and
one of the police men came up an officer
and he said sir I want to thank you my
401k is through the roof my wife thinks
I'm a brilliant investor I've never seen
anything like it my wife is so happy my
family is so happy dumb I don't think so
he's telling the stories that people
want to hear personalizing sterile
statistics charts and graphs real
anecdotes and though you know I got to
say thinking about dumb
I feel pretty dumb if I'd been one of
those GOP donors who was snookered into
writing a million-dollar check to Jeb
Bush the super PAC or if maybe in late
October 2016 I put down a payment on a
house in Georgetown because I was sure
that Hillary Clinton would win and I'd
be working in her administration there's
a brilliance in Trump's political
strategy perhaps his greatest instinct
was a simple message that resonated most
with his core supporters build the wall
that promise was sacrosanct and it
helped him get elected the best thing
Trump can do is to stick to his core
campaign promises especially that one
he's not gonna fall I don't think for
what the failed elites might be trying
to sell him they may have more political
experience and a lot of them do but he
has better instincts than most of them
and most Americans will see that his
thinking is exactly the type of
unconventional thinking that at times is
disruptive that we need right now and
that's the angle